Am I afraid of being buried
alive?
Yeah, I don’t think I’d love it.
I’d prefer to be buried alive
than to burn to death in a fire.
I would hate to be buried alive,
that’s why I’m going to get
cremated.
Ironically, I’d be, I’d still be
burned but that’s after I’ve...
Yeah, you wouldn’t be dead
before you’re burnt to death.
Yeah, I think that’s...
Uh, just to check in, how much
of this is usable?
(Laughing)
The first time I was like, I
really, really love doing these
scenes with you
and I want to do lots of more
scenes with you, was in episode
four at the gala.
I’m switching tables.
No, no, no, no, no, hey. Come on
back here.
Phil Dunster:
I loved watching you do that
because, you can see the depth,
Phil Dunster:
and like all the memories and
like the years of frustration and pain
but also like the ambition that
you had and the optimism that you
used to have
and I was like this is, I love
working with somebody who can do
that.
That’s the nicest thing you’ve
ever said.
I loved you from day one.
And I’m not ashamed to say it.
And I remember in the first read
through, I was like, you’re very
good you’re very good
because I always like an actor
who isn’t scared of the negative
aspects
of their character. That doesn’t
try to just charm them away, you
know what I mean?
Yeah.
If you could inhabit one of your
co-star's bodies for a day, who
would it be?
Yours. How ‘bout you? Whose...
Whose body would I inhabit if I
could?
Yeah, whose body would you
inhabit?
What you’re asking me, is, will
you objectify a member of the
cast?
And I absolutely would.
Phil Dunster:
Yeah.
But not, not in public.
There’s a bit when we head-butt
each other.
What’d ya do that for!?
So I could do this!
Yeah, and we left a scar on it.
Phil Dunster:
Yeah.
-Still have it to this day
‘cause we really went for it.
- Yeah. Mine's internal.
Mine’s here. But, do you know
what, Brett?
I think it’s one of those, it’s,
it’s one of those things
that just happened over time and
then one day I woke up
and I thought, gosh, I thought,
heavens.
He's in my bed again.
He's in my heart.
Yeah.
-And metaphorically in my bed.
-Yeah.
And wherever I go.
I can’t get through a scene with
you despite loving you and all
that
and I love doing scenes with
you. You make me laugh in every
scene
in a really bad way, like, like
we’re in church.
It's like someone’s farted and
you’re not allowed to laugh.
And I always wondered why it is,
and I think it’s
because we often have scenes
where we’re really close.
We do, yeah!
Brett Goldstein:
Our faces are always very close
to each other.
Phil Dunster:
Much proximity.
-Yeah.
Phil Dunster:
Do you remember?
Brett Goldstein:
Yeah.
Season two?
Yeah, I remember.
Phil Dunster:
There’s a scene where you hug
me.
Brett Goldstein:
That is the only scene I have
not laughed in because it was very moving
Brett Goldstein:
and you were so brilliant.
That was like a really special,
we were all in it.
We were really in that scene,
all of us.
Phil Dunster:
Yeah.
You also had to do that with a
massive audience,
like it wasn’t just the crew, it
was like everyone in the cast
was in that scene
Brett Goldstein:
and it was a long day, it was
all day doing that
and you’re right, everyone is
usually distracted
but I think you also held
everyone. It was really amazing.
Thanks, man.
You’re a good boy.
Who do you think on the show
would be easiest to deep fake?
I think it’s probably me
because I do the least amount of
movement.
That is true. Yeah.
So you just, you can just put
like my face on a stick and just
walk it around.
You’d probably be fine.
Phil Dunster:
In my mind you had a persona of,
you are one of the leads in this show,
Phil Dunster:
you’ve got a huge body of work
behind you,
but you are just as much of an
idiot as I am. Because you...
Brett Goldstein:
Yeah, yeah.
I remember you thinking...
I saw your eyes light up.
...you seem like really highbrow
and so clever and then you’d be
like beep boop beep.
Phil Dunster:
Yeah.
Brett Goldstein:
I’d be laughing and you’d be
like, oh, this is easy.
One of the first jokes that I
think we had was the...
Brett Goldstein:
Oh, yeah.
We’d start doing this because we
didn’t want people to hear us
doing these stupid voices.
Brett Goldstein:
Yeah.
And making silly noises.
Brett Goldstein:
And then sound came in
Phil Dunster:
Because we’re just silly, aren’t
we? We’re just silly.
Brett Goldstein:
Silly boys.
But, seriously, I love you.
I love you.
I think you’re amazing.
At this, at writing it, also
telling me which bits are,
like how to make it funny.
Cause I genuinely, I don’t know,
you know,
there’s times where I have to be
like, how do I say this when
it’s funny.
And I love you for teaching me
that
and thank you also for
having a really nicely sculpted
body.
Phil, you’re a fantastic actor.
Truly a brilliant actor, you can
do anything.
You can do anything. You can do
all the voices.
You can sing, you can dance.
You’ve taught me a dance move or
two.
I have.
You’re the funniest person I
know, probably.
Wow.
Top five.
Phil Dunster:
I know a lot of funny people,
I’m in comedy.
You do, you’re a comedian.
I know a lot of funny people.
-I’m, listen, I’m thrilled with
top five.
-I’m putting you top five.
Yeah.
Should we sign off with our
dance move?
No.
Do you wanna? You don’t wanna.
-We can do the face that you
taught, the dance face.
-Okay
Commit. Commit.
That's what they wanna see.
Okay, thank you very much.